ich finde es richtig ist dass zu
unterscheiden weil ich sag mal
berufssoldat zu werden er das ist ja
eine ganz andere komponente also das ist
ja nicht tralla city sondern das ist ja
auch eine gewissensentscheidung warum
man das auch ablehnt und auch aus
genauso guten gründen warum man sich
eben dazu bekennt nur wenn man dann
berufssoldat wird dann ist natürlich das
höchste primates das auf dem boden des
grundgesetzes passiert und das ist ja
auch der vorstoß von hügel dass sie auch
damit diesen rechtsextremismus bekämpfen
will
aber das sind zwei verschiedene sachen
und das ist sowieso die voraussetzung
für eine parlamentsarmee
das ist ja der vorteil den wir haben im
gegensatz zur usa wo das trump mit einer
unterschrift besiegeln kann dass das
hier gute gründe hat dass jeder einsatz
sozusagen durch das parlament auch
verabschiedet werden muss und das ist ja
nicht trivial und ich glaube viel
wichtiger sozusagen diese kultur
dahinter also auch der demokratie der
friedenssicherung das gilt ja nicht nur
deutschland sondern europaweit und da
macht es auf jeden fall sind diese
verschiedenen gesellschaftsmodelle zu
diskutieren aber wie gesagt ich plädiere
immer noch für freiwilligkeit
ja aber gerade da würde man ja dann die
chance ergreifen wenn es eine pflicht
wäre genau das zu schaffen mehr
integration alle sind 1 alle sind
arbeiten an der selben sache machen
dieselben erfahrungen man durchmischt
das ganze nun muss ja auch genau sagen
dass die bundeswehr ja viel mehr ist als
das für den ernstfall wie viel hat uns
die bundeswehr geholfen jetzt in dieser
krise mit krankenhäusern mit
unterstützung in krisengebieten in den
so genannten hot spot also es ist ja
nicht nur dass man dafür nicht vergessen
dass man sagt bundeswehr dienst an der
waffe die bundeswehr ist viel viel mehr
als das und wenn wir uns aber die
natürlichen ksk ist auch auflösung
rechtsextremismus da sein unwesen
getrieben hat gegen den heutigen zahlen
des verfassungsschutzberichtes sind
erschreckend ja auch das passiert das
gehört dazu und das dürfe natürlich
nicht weg blenden in dieser diskussion
[Musik]